cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com pacman the link is down
below
today we're going to take a deep dive
into critical race theory many people
have opinions about it
many of those very same people don't
know what it is but they know it's bad
no idea what it is but it must be bad so
we're going to take a look at critical
race theory a cultural issue
getting much attention over the last
couple of years
okay let's start with something that a
lot of people have asked me to talk
about on the show this is really
interesting the latest right-wing
buzzword that's getting people fired up
and angry is critical race theory
republicans are absolutely and
completely against the teaching of
critical race theory in schools they
want to ban it they believe it's
terrible it might even be communist or
socialist it's really really bad
but they don't actually know what it is
check out this interview that mark
lamont hill did with former georgia
congressman vernon jones a trumpian
favorite
who is really against critical race
theory but he has
no idea what it is check this out what
is critical race theory
well actually i think it's different
depends on who's teaching and how
they're teaching i think you can agree
with that uh we were taught that
christopher columbus discovered america
well you and i both know that
christopher columbus got lost people
already living here but there are those
who are using their own ideology
and their own party affiliation to go to
the extreme and that's all i'm trying to
address here
but what is that what does that have to
do with critical race theory
let me just pause
i'm trying to understand though
you oppose critical race theory which i
understand i'm just asking
what is it what is the thing you define
it like for example if i said i'm
against creationism i would say
creationism is x y and z right if i said
i was against the teaching of sex
education i said well sex education is x
y and z and i'd have a basis for it
what is critical race theory
well first of all again
i can tell you what is left of you to
understand i can't make you understand
fact of it is the critical race theory
even on this basis should not be taught
in our schools period now if you can't
understand what is it and if you want to
debate well to me
what it does to me my interpretation as
well as many others not what it does
what is it how do you define it i mean
that asks you to define critical race
theory because my audience may not know
well
you don't know and you have i said
obviously you don't know and you haven't
told your audience but again how i see
it
well well then what is it then
no what is it then okay well i'm happy
to answer that for you
but your answer you're saying just
answer it i'll tell you what i will
absolutely debate okay i'm waiting for
you to answer go going to answer it
i i i will just hold on one second
you're you're saying that on day one
on day one here's the question first
answer the first question i promise i'll
answer your questions so you get the
picture vernon jones just doesn't know
what it is that's just one example but
this is the bottom line they continue to
attack critical race theory without
actually indicating that they know what
it is when they're asked what it is they
seem to have no idea or
they say critical race theory is the
idea that every white person is a white
supremacist oppressor now we should
understand what critical race theory is
and i want to be really clear that
critical race theory is not my primary
lens through which i view the world i
find it reductionist but i'm going to
tell you what critical race theory is
and then you can research more you can
decide whether you think it's an
accurate lens or whether it should be
part of your uh world view okay the way
i see critical race theory is a sort of
race reductionism now if you've heard
the term
class reductionism
there's a very simple analogy to at
least give us an initial basic
understanding of critical race theory
although it's not nuanced enough and i
admit that
class reductionists believe that at some
fundamental level any division any
problem any conflict any inequality in
society
in politics in an economy
even if it seems it might be caused by
many things is actually about class
something that to a class reduction is
something that looks like a racial issue
uh to a class reductionist it's really a
problem caused by class differences and
the racial factors may just be
confounding or they may be coincidental
or they may not even be relevant so to
make a very rough analogy
to give us a start in understanding
critical race theory critical race
theory would analogously argue that what
might seem like a class problem or an
economic problem or a political problem
that it is actually fundamentally a
problem of race and racism in the us
specifically it would be racism
generally by white people against
non-white people in particular against
black americans now that's the most
basic explanation it's far more detailed
as an area of academic research now for
30 years and really even more than that
uh the roots of critical race theory are
in the 60s and 70s but
um without getting into you know a more
nuanced definition would include the
idea of creating subgroups of humans
developing law and systems that are
inherently racist and designed to
maintain these inequalities between
whites and non-whites and you can use
that analysis when you look at any
system you can look at the education
system through the lens of critical race
theory or the election system and on and
on now there are undoubtedly many ways
in which aspects of critical race theory
are completely accurate where i disagree
with critical race theory much the same
way i disagree with class reductionism
is that i don't think anything is quite
so simple on a planet of 7 billion
people in a country of 331 million like
the u.s we can never really say
this issue is solely informed by one
thing whether it's race whether i've
never found an issue
where
race is the one lens through which we
understand it or class is the one lens
or geography is the one
it's just never been that way
on any issue i've studied but this is
not about my view
this is about the reality
that the very people angrily denouncing
critical race theory have no idea what
it even is now i want to say one other
thing about that
this is not uncommon
think about the usage of the term
socialist during the last presidential
election i've asked lots of these people
when i interview them or when they call
in or when you know whatever what do you
mean socialist and they have no idea
what it means but they use it and they
believe joe biden is one now
cartoonishly as one example here's what
happened when conservative jessie lee
peterson brought it up when i visited
his studio in los angeles um and the
topic of socialism came up during the
trump administration take a look because
it's the straight white conservative
christian man who's holding the country
together if it wasn't for them america
would be associated with society already
it would be what a socialist
society how would it become if you see
if you notice the average black man has
no authority no power the mexican
doesn't have any is that white straight
conservative christian man that is
preventing them from turning this
country into a you know socialist
society but so here let me ask you about
this
i'm not a socialist myself i'm a social
just to be clear i'm i'm i don't i'm not
advocating for social media
i don't know that many actual socialists
like who would
who where's the big desire for the us to
become socialists if you look at the
democratic party there's almost no
socialists in the democratic ocean is a
communist party now what's one that's
one socialist idea from the democratic
socialized healthcare no that's a social
social democracy program no
denmark socialist and if you notice that
barack obama
the father messiah you know he's the
father messiah right
i don't know anything about that big
mama michelle
uh he tried to turn america into a
socialist society what's one example of
a socialist policy that he had uh
socialized healthcare he didn't do that
he did for-profit obamacare taking care
of everybody how so by getting rid of
jobs many people mostly took care of
people about getting into full-time jobs
and they had to work two part-time jobs
in order to survive so you don't even
understand the talking points the rest
stopped working and just went and
depended and relied on the government
free obama phones
that's socialism
so how can you so
i want to ask a real question
i'm asking you a real question obama
phones are not socialism now i'll answer
your question let me ask you a real
i really want to know this
the arguments against places like
venezuela and cuba
and other so-called socialist countries
are that no one has anything no one can
afford anything there's no technology
there's no food but you're saying that
cell phones for people are socialism
yeah that's your argument yes right
that's an example of it yeah so the
point is there's no difference here they
don't know what socialism is
they don't know what critical race
theory is the first step in every single
one of these conversations should be
ask them to define the terms and you
will very quickly see that they have no
idea what they are talking about all
right i think you're really gonna like
this clip or at least be horrified by it
in a sense that will be sort of
enjoyable but horrifying um we've talked
about the kind of like manufactured
nature
of the culture wars that the wright is
currently engaged in and the manufacture
manufactured can mean a couple different
things manufactured can be manufactured
by creating irrational fear
um
through lying to people and making them
think that something is a threat to
their way of life or to their family or
whatever so it could be manufactured
with lies to create fear um it can also
be considered manufactured in that it's
sort of like just based on either
misunderstandings or
factual discrepancies like about the
2020 election the big lie it's
unconstitutional
and states violated the rules and dead
people voted and mike pillow has access
to voting machines that show you all
these different things
and it becomes sort of a cultural thing
where even though you might say well
what what's the culture of claiming the
election was lost it's this cultural
fight where they see themselves as
engaged in a war
where it doesn't matter if they
literally believe the explanations as to
how the election was stolen
they see repeating that it was stolen as
being on the right team and fighting
this holy war of sorts quite frankly
one of the flash points so many of the
flashpoints in this include critical
race theory
war on christmas
communism and socialism coming to
america
um
you could you could argue the biden
dementia thing is part of the culture
battle um the big lie certainly there's
a whole list of these things and we we
can go on and talk about them critical
race theory is particularly interesting
because
even more per in in an even more
pronounced way than with socialism and
communism the people talking about it
don't even know what it means oh all the
vaccine stuff also would be another
element of this a lot of the people
saying critical race theory is just a
disaster they literally have no idea
what it is they have no idea what it
means they don't understand what it
means in context out of context they
just have no clue
this is a video that has gone viral
from the good liars who do these really
really great interviews the good liars
interviewed a virginia voter as many of
you know today is election day in
virginia we're going to be covering the
results live of the gubernatorial race
terry mcauliffe versus um uh glenn
younkin who's the republican candidate
very important race and there are really
important issues at stake the good liars
went and interviewed this guy uh
air force veteran at least according to
the hat the guy is wearing and said
what's the most important issue and the
guy said it's critical race theory and
when asked what it is the guy literally
has no idea what it is he just doesn't
know what's going on take a look at this
what's the most important issue in the
governor's race here in virginia getting
back to the basics of teaching children
not teaching them critical race theory
now
before even getting to the question what
is critical race theory it's not very
small government conservativey
to want the governor
to necessarily dictate school curriculum
i mean remember the these republicans
claim to have this principle they abide
by which is
you only involve government in
everything when absolutely necessary if
not you leave things leave it to school
boards leave it to municipalities leave
it right but here they want to elect
glenn younkin who has made a big deal
out if we got to get critical race
theory out and all these different
things
completely in violation of their
so-called
light touch conservative principles but
then here comes the question what is
critical race theory and uh and what is
critical race theory
well i'm not going to get into the
specifics of it because i don't
understand it that much but it's
something that i don't
what little bit that i know i don't care
for and and what have you heard that you
don't well
i'm not
you know
i don't uh
i don't i don't have that much knowledge
on it but it's something that i'm not
that i don't care for you know this is
like when a kid is presented with
you know broccolini for the first time
and the kid says
i don't like it i'm not trying it but
what about it don't you like you it
doesn't it doesn't taste good or you
don't like the tech i've never tried it
i don't like it i don't want it
okay right but what
i don't care for it the little i know
about it which is the fact that you're
trying to feed it to me
not good
i don't like it
it's a similar dynamic well maybe inform
yourself about what it is first and our
friend anna casparian over at the young
turks had a really good tweet about
sort of another aspect so how many
layers are there to this there's a lot
of layers there's people who are just
goaded into culture war issues by fear
and propaganda that's one aspect two the
general incompetence of the american
public which we will get to in the
voicemail segment
three is what anna tweeted which is this
is what manufactured culture wars
meant to distract you from elites
robbing this country blind
results in and folks like this guy they
would probably agr if a republican says
corporations are robbing you blind they
would probably agree in some general
sense to the extent that they understand
it
um if a republican said
you know even climate change is an issue
of patriotism like they would go for it
but very quickly all of those
substantive issues
including issues on which there aren't
big differences between republicans and
democrats who are part of the same
system that is not working for tens of
millions if not more
of americans
they get distracted with something like
critical race theory which this guy even
admits that he doesn't even know what it
means so
sad
funny depressing
kafka-esque to go back to the earlier
segment you tell me how you would
describe it one of our sponsors today is
cheese butter giving you 15
off i love this stuff cheese butter is a
delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye
pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry cheese
butter is giving my audience 15
off when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman hey david is critical race theory
actually dangerous like right winger say
or is it just kind of reductive yeah
this is good you know the
i've issued many critiques about
critical race theory on this show
i don't think it's dangerous
um i think as a general concept one can
always argue being uninformed can have
negative consequences and so you could
say well if you believe that no matter
how fast you drive you won't get hurt if
you get into a car crash yeah that's a
belief that's dangerous in a very
specific and tangible way
when it comes comes to critical race
theory
i wouldn't apply the word dangerous i i
do think however
that um
critical race theory could potentially
be harmful to race relations between
individuals that's number one
i do think critical race theory is
reductive in the way that it deals with
race over
many other factors that affect how
people relate to each other in modern
society
um and i've i've talked before about how
you know critical theories like critical
race theory
heavily are supported by ideas of
post-modernism and post-structuralism
and this is not me going all jordan
peterson talking about
post-modernism and that that's not it's
not this vague uh critique and i'm not
saying
uh anything beyond what i'm actually
saying
but
the basis of critical race theory
and the genesis of some of the ideology
and post-modernism and
post-structuralism
relies on
um
the ideas
in some combination
that reality is socially constructed
it's it's sort of an attack on
empiricism and it's a propping up of the
idea that
any reality any notion any analysis
could be just as real as any other
and in some cases taken to a very you
know extreme place
uh could be
deserves equal footing
in discussions about how society should
be organized
um and then one of the other
aspects of critical race theory that i
think is very problematic now by by the
way if you're gonna email me and you're
gonna say david that one piece doesn't
apply to all of critical race theory
fine i'm i'm talking in generalities
about things that exist within uh
enclaves of critical race theory
one of the really concerning things i
see
are
very very um casual
claims
levied against anyone who challenges
aspects of critical race theory that
merely by challenging critical race
theory you are a white supremacist
you are racist
you are an oppressor you were part of
the problem we saw this earlier this
week with the story about the seattle
pride event some pride event in seattle
that was only going to charge a fee to
white people how do you identify which
those people are i don't know and they
weren't calling it an admission fee they
were calling it a reparations fee to get
around saying
the admission is is
depending on race
um and then when some members of the
seattle city council said this this this
is bad this really doesn't make any
sense
they were accused of doing violence by
critiquing the plan of only charging the
reparations fee to the white attendees
that's a that's a non-starter for me
that's the opposite of rational inquiry
and uh so back to the question is
critical race theory actually dangerous
i think just about any idea if taken far
enough you could justify and say it
would be dangerous in this way
i think that it's incomplete i think
it's reductive and i think it's
counterproductive over the long term
to both race relations and achieving
real equality under the law and and in
society
which i think is an important add-on
because many areas we have equality
under the law
but for sociocultural reasons we don't
have actual equality that's my sense let
me know your thoughts you know we've had
a number of examples over the last
couple of weeks to a couple of months
of different things being equated to
being like the holocaust or like
world war ii or like historical attacks
on jews
and incorrectly so and now the sort of
natural and and predictable
next step in this is taking place which
is that we're starting to see segments
on right wing media
saying that teaching critical race
theory or certainly critical race theory
being
part of the
national understanding of how things
work is like the holocaust uh we're
going to have a clip of this with
right-wing radio host michael savage now
i do feel i know that some people get
angry when i do the disclaimers i feel
that it's necessary here
i am a uh a critic of critical race
theory i've critiqued critical race
theory along the lines that i've
critiqued other theories that come out
of the post-modernist and
post-structuralist ideology i've
critiqued critical race theory as
reductive but critical race theory is
not like the holocaust it's it's uh that
that's a wild and crazy thing to say uh
the daily beast summarizes news max goes
there critical race theory is the road
to death camps for white people
right-wing radio talker michael savage
declared the obscure academic theory
akin to the holocaust prompting a
supportive response from a newsmax tv
host
far-right radio host michael savage took
conservatives latest moral panic to a
bonkers new level during a monday night
news max appearance warning that the
teaching of so-called critical race
theory in schools is akin to exactly
what was done to the jews in germany now
that is not true we're going to look at
the video clip michael savage is a guy
we've covered on the program for a long
time
he is uh desperate to maintain some
level of relevance
and comparing things to the holocaust
especially when you yourself are jewish
and remember that that's something that
the right is playing up michael savage
is jewish um that makes it get more
attention it doesn't make it any more
accurate let's take a listen to this and
by the way
the people who decry the identity
politics say i don't know should we
listen to savage because he is jewish
after all maybe he can tell us what
things are like the holocaust here we go
i my blood's boiling listening to chuck
todd i wanted to reach through the
screen and smack him in the face
this is by the way if you're not
familiar with michael savage this is how
he normally talks and it's just a way
that he it it's part of his his shtick
essentially to talk in this he's just
constantly outraged at everything
everybody does he have children can you
imagine having a little child who goes
to school and is told that he's no good
his race is no good he's evil his
parents are evil his nation is evil
these are the same sobs who lectured us
for 20 years about don't be a bully
tolerate everything and now they're
beating up white children in school
rooms and i'm not going to mince words
you can cut me off if you have to i know
you probably agree with me i can't take
this anymore
and there's only one solution to it sue
the goddamn schools if they do it to
your child for child abuse now when he
says if they do it to your child for
child abuse
i have said before
i do think that as a starting point
uh teaching children
that they are
in some way part of a bad group because
of the color of their skin i'm against
that and that's bad
for the most part critical race theory
is taught to college students
and only in certain relevant classes
that college students have chosen to
take
what michael savage is referring to
which exists very anecdotally and i
would be against it but it is not really
the issue
is
certain exercises that have been done
in elementary or junior high schools
which
start to
sort of frame the question of
race and goodness and badness in a way
that i don't think is useful or
productive in any way to bettering race
relations but remember that this is part
of the ruse the vast majority of what
would fall under the guise of critical
race theory is being taught to college
students and it is being taught as
theory it is not being taught as you
were bad for this reason or that reason
that relates to your skin color so the
whole framing here is wrong but let's
get to the really crazy part you will
win
because that's the only way to stop this
these children are being humiliated and
hurt and damaged for life
by a psychotic woman who came up with
this lie called critical race theory
which is nothing but racism towards
white people no other race is targeted i
could go on and i can go on and on i've
studied history i know where this starts
i know where it ends it started in the
same kind of thing started in germany
the jews were no good the jews did this
the jews did that the next thing you
knew they were being excluded from
swimming pools they didn't put them in
concentration camps overnight i studied
this intimately what's really
interesting about that the analogy to
the holocaust is completely wrong
but
michael savage says something really
interesting there which is he says it
didn't happen overnight
that phrase very accurately describes
the creeping authoritarianism and
nuttery that we saw under donald trump
if on the day after trump was elected in
2016 i had told you by the end of this
trump will be
trying to steal an election he clearly
lost
um trying to
use the department of justice and all of
these different uh um
aspects of government to do his bidding
demanding that the supreme court do x y
and z
all of the different mishandling a
pandemic during which he will suggest
that um infected americans be sent to
guantanamo bay nobody would have
believed it if i had said that on you
know november 8th of 2016 or whatever
the date was
but it slowly creeps in to the point
where by the time those things were
happening the response was nowhere near
what it should have been
it doesn't apply here to critical race
theory but it would have applied if
michael savage had talked about this in
relation to trump's creeping
authoritarianism just a few more seconds
here i'm jewish i know how this starts
attacking that's identity politics by
the that's the identity politics they
decry because he's jewish
he must be right about what things are
like the holocaust on white people is
exactly what was done to the jews in
germany in the 30s don't fall for this
garbage this is the road to the death
camps stand up to these bastards and sue
them
yeah so there is michael savage and it
is yet another analogy to the holocaust
that makes absolutely no sense and the
sad thing about this is
there there are real serious critiques
of critical race theory as an academic
theory
when you go to
this is like jews being excluded from
swimming pools and the precursors to
concentration camps you just lose it and
i would i would actually
respect one of these right wingers in
their opposition to critical race theory
much more
if they just levied a sober and sensible
critique that's not what we're seeing
from people like michael savage don't
forget that the best way to support the
david pakman show is by becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials you also get access to
our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
i want to talk a little bit about a
critical race theory protest
gone completely haywire in ashburn
virginia
the school board of this wealthy county
loudoun county in virginia
wanted to hold a meeting to close out
the school year
and it became complete and total chaos
in this washington dc suburb as parents
who apparently are against critical race
theory although it's not completely
clear they really know what it is they
wanted to protest critical race theory
we're going to look at some video clips
here this is wild wild stuff here is one
parent
um
the founder of parents against critical
race theory
speaking to a crowd outside the event
take a listen to this
all they keep doing is changing the
narrative clinical race theory is
culturally responsive framework
culturally responsive teaching
it's all just trojan horses
inequity diversity and inclusion
you know come on you know one thing
yeah who would want any of that stuff
guys i mean that's just crazy it's crazy
what they're trying to teach now i i am
a critic of critical race theory um
this you know we one of the things that
happens in academia is you have a theory
and then you have critiques of the
theory
and that's all normal and good uh but we
don't we don't want to teach inclusion
we don't want to teach the value of
equality i mean it's he doesn't even
really seem to understand what critical
race theory is
then of course they broke into the
national anthem listen to this
[Music]
i think you get the the impression this
is not it's it's they're just standing
in the parking lot singing the national
anthem again
if you were to satire
um sort of like ignorant clueless
uh protests of critical race theory this
is what they would look like um then the
crowd inside the event wouldn't shut up
and they had to threaten to end the
meeting disgusted by your mega drink
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so there were threats that if these
people don't quiet down they're gonna
have to uh end the meeting uh and then
they did actually end the public comment
section and people went completely nuts
[Music]
oh my goodness
so that was after the announcement that
they were going to have to wrap the
thing up because people were going
completely crazy um and things just
continued getting wilder and wilder take
a look
oh this is when they go back into the
national anthem the meeting was ended
and they go back into the national
anthem
[Music]
dear god
[Music]
so that went on and then um then the
arrest started happening uh here is you
will this is while an arrest is going on
you i think in this clip you hear
someone yell who pays your salary to the
police officers as well
there it is
[Music]
okay so people getting completely
outraged i guess they're mad at
everything getting mad at the police
getting mad at the school board getting
mad at the t everybody's furious with
everybody and then this is sort of like
the cherry on top here is a guy
uh getting getting himself arrested uh
in the midst of this
[Music]
by the way you know we we talk about
resisting arrest is used as a catch-all
when police want to manhandle someone um
by the standards we normally see apply
to what counts as resisting arrest this
guy's doing it and police treating him
very very politely as you can tell
this is an unpopular arrest
first commandment
listen
you're right
so listen
listen to me
at this point
[Music]
the officer says the meeting is over and
the guy says it's not you can see if
you're watching the video that there's
almost no one left so the meeting
clearly is over i think that's more of
an empirical question the meeting has
ended but just another complete and
total humiliation and
this is sort of a mind virus this is an
example of where
the idea of critical race theory
as an indoctrination strategy in high
schools has spread like a virus among
some of these right wingers and they can
no longer think sensibly they can no
longer behave like adults it's a real
sad thing to see
but they seem to have really latched on
to this in a pretty serious way
i don't expect this to go away anytime
soon and we may do even a deep dive on
critical race theory at some point in
the next few weeks because it is
becoming i mean listen
these are adults supposedly and look at
what the idea the misunderstood idea
that they have of critical race theory
has done to them
i'm all for serious critiques of
critical race theory i've done them i
think it's reductive and i i think it's
not uh the type of theory that will
further race relations
but i'm not gonna be showing up uh and
getting myself arrested and screaming i
i'm just glad to talk to people about it
in a calm sensible and rational way i
don't expect this to end anytime soon
we'll have some more of these clips on
the show's instagram which you can find
at davidpakmanshow you can also find me
on instagram at david.pacman we'll take
a quick break and be right back all
right this is a super interesting story
and a very different um uh sort of
military related story than what many of
us have become accustomed to
yesterday the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff general mark milley
was asked
questions by republican congressman matt
gates about the u.s military
examining critical race theory now the
the term examining is really the
appropriate term
understanding marxian economics doesn't
make you a marxist and much the same way
examining critical race theory doesn't
make you someone
who
guides their philosophy or runs a
military on the basis of critical race
theory although you may learn something
that's relevant or furthers your
understanding or maybe not but the point
is simply understanding something
examining it learning about it
doesn't actually dictate your political
philosophy and uh matt gates
and others were just uh getting after
general mark milley
and he delivered a concise
and very astute explanation of why i
mean forget about just critical race
theory there's a bigger issue here which
is
the right he doesn't say the right but
i've been pointing out the right seems
to fail to understand the value of
diverse knowledge
for its own sake
rather than necessarily as a tool of
indoctrination so let's take a look at
this clip this is general mark milly
super super interesting stuff you'll see
the camera if you're watching go to matt
gates at one point who's just sort of
shaking his head and he doesn't like it
but he seems to know he's being schooled
right now take a look mr chair and thank
you gentlemen for joining us today i
know my time is very precious but i
would like to yield some of my time to
general milley because i know that he
had some comments that he wanted to make
when representative gates was talking as
well as mr waltz about a similar subject
of the stand down and race theory would
you like a minute or so to comment on
that do you remember what we were what
your line of questioning or thought was
there
um sure um first of all
on the issue of critical race theory etc
i'll obviously have to get much smarter
on whatever the theory is
but i do think it's important actually
uh for those of us in uniform
to be open-minded and be widely read and
the united states military academy is a
university
and it is important that we train and we
understand uh and i i want to understand
white rage
understand what he's pointing out here
right
the military trains for many
contingencies which never happen
the military trains to understand
circumstances
uh which may be good bad neutral or
irrelevant because that's what you do
you prepare you learn you understand
similarly
when you apply that and say hey this is
a university you learn things in
university from
math i mean listen have i used calculus
2
in my work life no
but understanding it and going through
it has been extraordinarily valuable in
terms of now i understand how do we even
learn
math at that level which is not a
particularly high level but i'm not i'm
not bragging but i'm just saying i'm not
using it but it's still useful and much
the same way we should be seeing
some of this these ideologies and and
theories as well right now that's an
academic it's it's the most basic thing
right about what we what learning is
want to understand it so
what is it that cause thousands of
people to assault
this building and try to overturn the
constitution of the united states of
america what caused that right i want to
find that out i want to maintain an open
mind here and i do want to analyze it
it's important that we understand that
because our soldiers sailors airmen
marines and guardians they come from the
american people so it is important by
the way guardians that's the space force
trump thing i i he you know he has to
say it it just it sounds so weird to
hear it that the leaders
now and in the future do understand it
i've read miles seitang i've read i've
read karl marx i've read lenin that
doesn't make me a communist this i mean
this is the this is literally the
example i gave earlier in the show
when i was at the university of
massachusetts amherst one of the few
then uh economics programs which
seriously taught what the class was
marxian economics with the with the late
uh steven resnick a co-author with
richard wolff uh in many articles and
and even books i believe um it didn't
turn me into a marxist but i i learned
what is the theory what is the genesis
we we read mark there was nothing
dangerous going on it's called being
informed uh and to hear mark milley say
it i have to tell you is fantastic so
what is wrong
with understanding having some
situational understanding about the
country for which we are here to defend
and i personally find it offensive
that we are accusing the united states
military our general officers our
commission non-commissioned officers of
being quote woke or something else
because we're studying some theories
that are out there that was started at
harvard law school years ago and it
proposed that there were laws in the
united states anti-bellum laws prior to
the civil war that led to a power
differential with african-americans that
were three-quarters of a human by the
way the general knows much more about
all of these topics than matt gates but
that probably doesn't come as a surprise
to anybody being when this country was
formed and then we had a civil war and
emancipation proclamation to change it
and we brought it up to the civil rights
act in 1964 it took another hundred
years to change that so look it i do
want to know and i respect your service
and you and i are both green berets but
i want to know
and it matters by the way it's not matt
gates that's the green beret it's a
different congressman who's there
military in the discipline and cohesion
of this military and i thank you for the
opportunity to make a comment on that
thank you general so the general is
completely right this is just called
thinking this is called being a student
of things this is called learning
uh understanding and um it it makes
absolute perfect sense
that uh this would be the perspective
that an entity like the military would
take and um it doesn't mean the military
becomes woke in the negative sense of
the of the term now just just to give
you one reaction to this which is so
funny
after this last night laura ingraham on
fox news responded to this and she said
the reason this happened is because of
democrats and the military-industrial
complex this she's like a trapeze artist
she's a she's a contortionist i don't
know how this is what she comes up with
but let's listen the active duty service
men and women about that sir
now somehow i don't think general milley
would ever speak in this dismissive tone
that he took today to his chinese
counterparts
not the way he spoke to congressman
waltz who questioned him what i have a
question for the general
why would anyone risk his or her life
for a country that's systemically racist
one that brutalizes minorities this is
what you call black and white thinking
let's assume for a second that it wasn't
just that mark milly said
let's understand critical race theory
imagine for a second that what mark
milley said was
the military will now see critical race
theory as its guiding explanation and
system for understanding the country
that's not what he said but imagine that
mark milley went as far as to say that
now laura ingram says why would anyone
be in the military to defend a country
that's structurally racist well you
underst if for those who subscribe to
critical race theory presumably the next
step is how do we fix it
and the same or similar motivation that
would lead someone
if they join the military for the right
reasons which is well for
i mean we can argue about whether the
military is used in this way but if you
join not to go and kill people as some
some do but most don't if you join the
military to try to make the country
better
and if you believe critical race theory
you would then want to change things to
make the country better in both cases
you're trying to make the country better
so her this black and white thinking of
if there's any systemic racism then you
wouldn't even be in the military because
you'd not want to defend a country
that's systemically racist it's just
gutter black and white thinking why
would any country respect us or follow
our lead if that's who we are
those are some of the questions he
should probably think about before he
touts the value of teaching far left
marxist racist ideology to our troops
and again all he touted was
we want to understand
what are the conversations that are
happening and what are the arguments
being made he never said
let's become a woke critical race theory
military that had he said that it would
be a different discussion
the fact is millie has made his choice
and he's chosen to indulge the radical
whims of democrats
he'll do everything they tell him as
long as they keep the
military-industrial complex flush with
cash
and of course that's just so silly
given that you know
military-industrial complex is almost as
big of an issue in terms of blind
support from democrats than from
republicans a little bit less
you do hear some democrats say we've got
to pare this down so for laura ingram
now to say well that this is all
happening he's taking a left perspective
because of democrats funneling money
into the military-industrial complex
republicans do far more of it so it's it
makes no sense one way or the other and
very interesting to see
the statements by general mark milley if
you value what we do at the david pakman
show remember to support us on patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show this is
just absolutely bonkers off the wall and
it's really instructive in terms of this
idea of neutrality versus objectivity
that i've been talking about for years
at this point there is a texas school
official that has been caught on an
audio recording saying that when
teachers teach about the holocaust
there should also be opposing views
what does that mean it's not clear but
it sounds pretty horrible we have the
audio first let me just kind of get you
up to speed with what uh this is about
uh npr reporting in one texas district
teachers were told to give opposing
views of the holocaust what
a texas school school district is again
the center of controversy after an
administrator reportedly instructed
teachers to provide students with
opposing views of the holocaust
gina petty the executive director of
curriculum and instruction for the
carroll independent school district in
south lake texas
is alleged to have made the comments
during last friday's meeting according
to nbc news which has audio
um let's just go right to the audio why
not uh this is
gina petty seeming to say we need
opposing views about the holocaust and
make sure that if
if you have a book on the holocaust that
you have one that has a closing
that has others how
gina petty did not respond to messages
requesting comment i met with two
concerned teachers yeah
opposing views guys opposing views about
the holocaust now this is a great
opportunity to again say
neutrality and objectivity are two
different things
there are many
uh individuals who profess neutrality
when neutrality is not nearly is not at
all objective
uh this is an issue on climate this is
an issue in many areas of life and of
discussion when we're being objective
we're honestly seeking the truth
whatever the truth turns out to be
no matter how it might differ from my
preconceived notions or my biases going
in that's objectivity we just want the
truth and we're not going to kneecap
hamstring or limit our search for the
truth on the basis of our personal
biases
neutrality is about a preconceived
balance
or agnosticism
between different positions
where the truth doesn't actually matter
notice that neutrality has nothing to do
with truth
it's just this idea where you're
pre-committing
to being indifferent or neutral
uh or agnostic between different
conclusions or ideas
so when we apply to the holocaust what's
an opposing view to the holocaust like
we should include
not only
real history books about the holocaust
but also
like nazi books about how nazis felt
about jews
like we shouldn't we should include
the the explanation of
nazis as to why the jews deserve to die
and students can determine was the
holocaust good or was the holocaust bad
like is that what we're talking about or
we should give a perspective as to why
hitler's goals were noble worthy and
good goals like what what does it
actually mean to have an opposing view
of the holocaust we need the often
misunderstood perspective of the nazis
really needs to be explained to kids and
of course that's part of what we teach
most
serious holocaust studies and you know
what's going on in texas i don't know
but i would hope that it it also is the
case
would include the views of the nazis and
why the nazis believed that the jews had
to die uh as well as those who uh have
medical issues and you know we could go
on and give the whole whole list that's
part of the actual books that should be
used so this is absolutely insane
as is mentioned in the
npr article
gina petty is the name of the woman
allegedly on the recording there
she was asked for comment and so far has
not delivered any comment but the the
right question is the one that you hear
on the audio there
how do you oppose the holocaust
to which petty responded believe me
that's come up now the school district
head has apologized and said
there are not two sides of the holocaust
that's lane ledbetter who put out a
statement saying as the superintendent
of schools i express my sincere apology
regarding the online article and news
story released today
during the conversations with teachers
during last week's meeting
the comment the comments made were in no
way to convey that the holocaust was
anything less than a terrible event in
history additionally we recognize there
are not two sides to the holocaust as we
continue to work through implementation
of hp3979 we also understand this bill
does not require an opposing view on
historical facts as a district we will
work to add clarity to our expectation
for teachers apologize for hurt or
confusion that this has caused now
here's the thing
um
that they may be accurately saying we're
not talking about two sides on the
holocaust
but this house bill 3979 as karen
fitzgerald a spokesperson said for the
district teachers acro across the state
are put in a precarious position by this
bill
our purpose is to support our teachers
in ensuring they will have all of the
professional development resources and
materials needed our district has not
and will not mandate books be removed
nor will we mandate that classroom
libraries be unavailable
but it still does put teachers in a
precarious position where
they have to ultimately say
there is no controversy to teach here
whereas in other areas like on climate
change the entire point of these bills
is to claim there is a controversy and
that it must be that the science of
climate
has to also be opposed by something else
and of course that's very different uh
different situations so while i guess
they're apologizing for saying we need
opposing views on holocaust studies
this is a very problematic bill and
we've continued to see these problematic
bills come out of texas
we'll see ultimately where this lands
hey david why don't republicans focus on
policy
instead of culture war issues wouldn't
it be better for them electorally
i don't know that it would be
and the reason that i say that is
it's not clear to me
that republicans actually have the
support to win on the issues
if repub what what was it that donald
trump did
that prior republicans didn't do that
essentially gave trump the victory in
2016. it was that he ran a campaign
based on cultural issues
and personal attacks
and fears about communism socialism
hillary etc
where
his voters didn't actually have to
evaluate policy and say does the policy
actually uh sound good to me
some examples where the republican party
if they were to run on policy would have
a problem
abortion is still used to raise a lot of
money by republican candidates but the
truth is that the american public is
more in favor of abortion being legal in
most cases than it has at any time in
the roe v wade era so if republicans
really made abortion a bigger issue it
might not be so good for them uh if you
look at the republican perspective on
taxation when you really get down to it
i've said a lot of bad things about the
populist movement and how they can
bamboozle people
but one of the things that
the more populist republican base has
gone towards
is
to be more hostile
to tax plans that are just good for rich
people now trump still passed one that
is mostly that but because policy was so
secondary and the cultural issues were
more important trump was able to achieve
an electorate that really doesn't care
very much what his policy is most of the
things he promised he was never going to
be able to do and it didn't even matter
no one actually held him accountable and
ultimately what brought trump down was
his mishandling of the coveted pandemic
i maintained that if the coveted
pandemic hadn't happened
and
because trump mishandled it right
there's the idea well trump could have
handled it well and won yeah trump was
not going to handle it well if trump
didn't end up having to mishandle kovid
he almost certainly would have been
reelected and to me when you say why
doesn't the republican party run on
policy it seems to me it's actually
better for them electorally to run on
these cultural issues we're against
critical race theory nobody can even
define it these people barely know what
it is
but it gets so much oxygen think about
the coverage of critical race theory on
fox news over the last three to four
months and then think of how it fires up
the base and it spreads i mean these
memes spread like wildfire
money is raised i'm coming out in
opposition of critical race theory in
schools donate to me
imagine if the entire time it had been
about like tax policy
they would not have gotten the attention
that they did and so to me it actually
seems you know same thing with we're
against communism and socialism joe
biden's making us a communist nation you
ask these people what is communism they
have no idea
and this allows them to continue moving
forward without ever really having to be
accountable for bad policy by just not
talking about policy i actually am
increasingly of the mindset that
republicans do better right now
by talking about the cultural issues
than they do uh by actually switching
over to policy check out my segment from
earlier this week
whether a culture war is even winnable
because that's another factor that the
left has to consider but i don't think
that
i think it's
disgusting in terms of the debasement of
american political discussion that
there's one party that doesn't even
pretend to care about policy that's
really bad for the country
but i think it's probably in a sense
the better choice for the republican
party in terms of winning elections
because they have a constituency
that wants to just fight and yell and
scream and cheer about cultural issues
and they don't really want to deal with
policy in any serious way that's why
trump won in 2016 were not for covid he
would have won in 2020 as well
send me your thoughts if you disagree
with me i do want to hear from you we
have a great bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpacman.com
get instant access and we will see you
then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagel sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below